[Musica]
sarajevo sotto assedio
c'è un grande poeta bosniaco izet
sarajlic potrebbe andare via perché
altri poeti lo potrebbero ospitare lo
invitano in altri paesi d'europa ma
decide di restare resta un giornalista
gli fa la domanda come puoi giudicare
descrivere raccontare un secolo così
crudele risponde non ti permetto di
parlare male di questo secolo perché in
questo secolo è nata la donna che ho
amato una donna salva un secolo
ognuno di noi può salvare un secolo gli
ato misti consideravano che l'anima
fosse fatta di piccole particelle che si
disgregano invadono il circostante
entrano in ognuno di noi praticamente
adesso stiamo respirando cile anime
secondo gli ato misti allora mi piace
pensare che il lavoro dei narratori dei
reporter sia come quello di
trasportatori di atomi di anime da un
continente all'altro e mi piace pensare
che possiamo portare di qua le storie di
quelle donne e quegli uomini che salvano
un secolo
allora di porto la da nada l'ho
fotografata senza testa
forse perché pensavo che al posto di
quella testa ci poteva essere quella di
ciascuno di noi
o forse perché
la guerra siriana ha decapitato un
popolo intero
la da l'ho conosciuta al confine tra il
libano e la siria sotto la tenda di
fortuna fatta con i cartelloni
pubblicitari e mi ha raccontato la sua
storia breve ve la racconto anche lei
come sala in lì c'era sotto assedio in
siria sono rimasti senza cibo perché
l'assedio è anche questo
il marito è uscito per cercare da
mangiare non è più tornato dopo 3 giorni
qualcuno le ha detto che il marito era
morto ucciso dai cecchini quindi in a da
ha preso le due bambine è uscita di casa
e attraverso una serie di avventure e
disavventure è arrivata in libano
cos'è un confine e un confine lo
attraversato tante volte ho attraversato
in aereo in macchina a piedi
tante volte anche a piedi ma credo di
non averlo mai visto se non nelle sue
conseguenze in fondo non è così
importante vedere per raccontare
altrimenti il più grande narratore di
tutti i tempi ovvero lo sarebbe stato
cieco perché è un vero è come se ci
dicesse che per raccontare
bisogna comprendere intelligere intuitus
indagare il principio che regge la
storia il principio di giustizia che la
porta avanti e quindi per raccontare
bisogna amare e comprendere ma qui
torniamo al confine
che per amare comprendere io ho bisogno
di relazione
anche questo è un confine difficilissimo
tra me e voi io ho bisogno di relazione
carlo bo minsky ha scritto sono così
distante da me che senza te te non mi
raggiungerei mai io non mi raggiungo
senza di te non ci riesco e più stringo
il mio confine più mi inserisco più non
trovo altri atomi per alimentarmi allora
vi porto in un altro confine molto più
lontano andiamo in congo del congo si
parla pochissimo il congo è un paese
grande otto volte l'italia
voi pensate a una pietra preziosa rara
in congo c'è tanto che viene definito
scandalo geologico addirittura c'era il
caucciù a inizio secolo dallo più
inventa lo pneumatico il congo è pieno
di alberi di caucciù risultato per i
congolesi tra i 9 ei 13 milioni di morti
e poi in congo già loro ci sono i
diamanti c'è l'uranio che è servito per
costruire l'atomica c'è il coltan senza
il coltan non potrei farvi vedere questa
foto andrebbero i nostri computer o
cellulari funzioniamo tecnologicamente
grazie al congo e nessuno vi parla del
congo
noi giornalisti siamo scarsi o forse gli
editori sono scarsi allora sono andata a
vedere una miniera una miniera di
cassiterite lui un minatore ha solo lo
scalpello e martello e una lucetta che
si mette in testa vive
per giorni e giorni giorni e mesi in una
tenda anche lui viene pagato solo quando
trova la pietra il suo lavoro e dentro
al cunicolo lungo 20 metri e sprofondate
per 30 sono entrata chi mi accompagnava
è rimasto fuori
sono arrivata a gatto lando con la
telecamera a 5 metri
dopodichè ho iniziato a sentire dei
rumori amplifica tissi mi che arrivavano
dal fondo di acqua di urla di risate che
io ho preso una paura che mai e sono
corsa fuori
naturalmente i minatori grandi fuori
sono scoppiato in una grandissima risata
e joseph uno di loro mi ha preso mi ha
detto anna ma di cosa hai paura non vedi
che quella è una porta e dietro una
porta cosa c'è c'è a casa
tu hai paura entrare in casa nostra
altra lezione per narratori cercare la
prospettiva inedita cercare sempre la
prospettiva inedita e ancora che fare
con il vedere ma non con la vista la
folla
spinge avanti l'adultera faccio un salto
nel vangelo la trascina gesù scrive per
terra scrive qualcosa che non lo sapremo
mai l'unica volta che scrive
probabilmente non lo sapremo perché non
è quello il fatto importante
il fatto importante è che lui non alzi
lo sguardo e cioè non aumenta con i suoi
occhi il gravoso dolore della folla
sulla donna
neanche di due occhi ancora la vista e
poi cosa fa disgrega la folla con un chi
gli basta dire chi chi è senza peccato
chi in quel modo
spacca il buio di ciascuno io li vedo in
violente arrogato allora volo magari
appoggia la pietra con l'altro al re tra
l'altro si guarda intorno
chi è pian piano se ne vanno e adesso
cominciano i problemi per l'adultera
perché davanti all'unico che la può
uccidere quello senza peccato
e lui cosa fa la guarda bellissimo non
la vede la guarda la guarda con l'amore
e di ci puoi andare lei non è stata
vista è stata guardata è stata amata e
non può peccare più
perché vi ho citato il vangelo intanto
le religioni sono delle che noi crediamo
meno delle narrazioni fenomenali
narrazioni fenomenali ma perché noi
giornalisti spesso per vincere facile
mettiamo i nostri occhi insieme a quelli
della folla perché la folla è la stessa
che compra noi uniamo i nostri occhi
alla folla invece dovremmo guardare dove
gli altri non guardano solo i
giornalisti perché unendo i nostri occhi
alla folla noi facciamo altro che
aumentare lo stigma invece dobbiamo
evitarlo allora ho avuto modo di
lavorare in diverse parti dove lo stigma
lo fa da padrone per esempio a scampia
facile dire che uno scarpino un
delinquente
ho lavorato in salvador con quelli che
la cia definisce i più pericolosi
delinquenti al mondo i più ferrati
delinquenti al mondo
ho lavorato in guatemala in guatemala
c'è un quartiere acida de guatemala che
si chiama la limonata ed è un quartiere
pericolosissimo non c'entra più nessuno
le pareti sono crivellate di proiettili
voi pensate di entrare in una specie di
imbuto di girone infernale dominato da
delle bande e la sfida liszt e trovare
ciò che non è inferno nell'inferno e
allora lì ho conosciuto mister fair un
altro che salva il secolo
mister fair non ha più neanche un amico
d'infanzia perché sono tutti morti
perché i suoi amici hanno preso in mano
una pistola
invece lui ballava e cantava hip hop e
rap l'arte alla la stessa forza delle
armi non l'hanno ucciso e l'unico
sopravvissuto allora aperto una scuola e
i ragazzi di mister fede
nessuno li tocca ma allora la domanda è
c'è sempre l'umano si trova sempre
l'uomo la donna che salvano il secolo io
finora avuto la fortuna di trovare un
grande maestro robert capa a un certo
punto si ferma e prende quello che
potremmo definire un buco clamoroso si
ferma lui che cercava luogo in tutte le
guerre si ferma l'apertura dei campi di
concentramento perché lì l'uomo era
stato annichilito annullato reso nulla
da un altro uomo e non fotografa k ci
insegna il coraggio del vuoto del
silenzio della pagina bianca nella foto
dallo scattare perché comunque
raccontare e anche un'azione politica
con la p maiuscola
le ultime parole le riservo a una
giornalista solange vichy che è morta
circa un mese fa incubo dove mi trovavo
e ha lasciato sette bambini sette figli
è una donna molto coraggiosa che ha
portato avanti diverse denunce mi piace
ricordarla cui con voi
allora lei non poteva stampare a bukavu
in congo andava oltre confine a
bujumbura burundi poi riempiva le
valigie di riviste ri attraversava il
confine vi assicuro che la strada da lia
la durissima e pericolosa e trafugando
racconti solange nella sua breve vita ha
spostato dei confini
allora la domanda vera è che cosa c'è di
là dal confine ma ancora che cosa volete
vedere voi di dada un confine ogni
giorno ogni confine i confini secondo me
gli uomini non li dovrebbero maneggiare
non sono adatti e aveva istituito una
natura un mare la montagna un fiume un
albero poi gli uomini cosa hanno fatto
hanno reso navigabile il fiume hanno
solcato i mari scalato le montagne i
bambini si sono trovati a giocare sugli
alberi
allora forse la natura ha messo proprio
i confini perché persone diverse
si incontrassero e si raccontassero e
allora forse ognuno di noi si deve
chiedere quale sarà il suo racconto
se un racconto che separa o un racconto
che unisce grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]